je dis aux québécois et aux québécoises
à vous maintenant de faire le choix de
seul choix qui s'avère intéressant pour
l'avenir du québec
ça suffit on est tanné font enfin
s'occuper des vraies the most pense que
ce qu'on a besoin au québec c'est se
donner un signal peuvent donner le mot
art été tourné en rond on va demander
aux québécoises et aux québécois de
voter sur des idées sur des programmes
sur des convictions
c'est au québec un pays
le parti québécois vient de choisir l'un
des patrons les plus intransigeants
terme électoral pour empêcher qu'un
référent on a deux courants avec la
coalition a mené québec il reprend de
référendum mais on voit aussi mieux
gérer il n'y aura pas de référendum tant
que les québécois ne sont pas prêts si
vous voulez reconnaître que les neuf
anick bérard ont donné de la merde on a
actuellement bien changé est-ce qu'on
veut revenir à ce qu'on a connu
si monsieur charest même vision même
équipe en perspective même problème
d'éthique
si elle choisit de le faire au débat
avec des projections tout est possible
merci ils vont dire oui on le sait sa
part sur un gouvernement libéral
majoritaire le cercle on continue jeudi
soir nous allons célébrer la victoire du
parti québécois
je